China's premier has asked the European
Union for help in sourcing urgent
medical supplies to deal with the
worsening coronavirus outbreak 259
people have now died from the virus that
was after China announced a further 46
deaths earlier Australia joined the u.s.
in banning visitors who've traveled to
China in American citizens who've been
in China for the past two weeks will now
also be screened and quarantined for two
weeks we've also heard from the World
Health Organization's representative in
China who's defended the decision to
declare the outbreak a public health
emergency
he's also warned there'll be no respite
from the spread of the virus in the near
future this increase is likely to
continue because there are almost as
many specimens waiting to be South
studied as there are already reported so
the numbers will continue to grow his
Scott hunter in Beijing with the latest
not great then that China is now having
to ask the EU for help no it's not a
great sign at all is it no we know that
you know over the last week 10 days that
there has been concern about just how
how much medical supplies are going to
be needed for this and obviously that
that has been growing because we're
seeing a growing number of those
infected we are seeing growing at
growing numbers of those dead so we knew
that there is going to be a greater need
and it just doesn't seem like it's being
met here in China so obviously the Prime
Minister Li Keqiang made a statement
saying that he's hoping to work with the
EU to procure more medical equipment it
didn't go into detail as to what exactly
they're looking for you know they're
they're hastily building to hospitals
down in Wuhan and then starting
construction on one outside here in
Beijing that was a temporary hospital
built during the SARS epidemic but those
two and Wuhan you know you got almost
2,500 new beds in two hospitals that are
going to me need to be equipped so I can
imagine just those two hospitals and the
need for equipment medical equipment
would be great but then you have all the
other existing hospitals and the other
existing needs they have we knew you
know a mid last week that there was a
call out for more protective clothing
for the medical professionals who are
treating those
had been infected so I would imagine
that's one of the things they're looking
for a lot of that the those materials
are manufactured here in China but I
would imagine that it just can't be
manufactured quickly enough you also
have situations where maybe some plants
are in areas as some factories are in
areas that are really shut down because
of the virus itself so you've got this
difficult situation but a call out from
Prime Minister Li Keqiang looking to get
more medical supplies particularly from
the EU here into China and what about
the travel restrictions Scott the
reaction to that because again it's just
another negative sign for China having
to deal with with the restrictions being
put on by other countries absolutely now
it wasn't received well the United
States has move to restrict non-citizens
who've been been in China from getting
into the United States that doesn't
include green card holders and relatives
of citizens close relatives of citizens
that was not received well here at all
actually they said it was not a show of
good faith is how they worded it here
the central government in Beijing but
one thing that citizen yes you know the
travel has been restricted in the Hebei
province you've gotten even more
restrictions almost every day within
China the Chinese government is actually
chartering planes to get people who are
tourists stuck who are Chinese citizens
who are stuck in Hubei Province to get
them out obviously they'll be screened
first to get them out of the province
and into their home provinces here in
China so that's obviously something to
try to alleviate maybe some of the
stress that that province is already
facing and one other thing I'd like to
know you know we we were talking about
this last hour come on you know Apple
has announced that it's closing its
offices and stores at least for a week
and all across China in mainland China
for at least a week they're going to
reevaluate this is following Starbucks
has done something similar McDonald's
has done something similar here but one
thing to look at in Hubei Province you
know you talked about the economic
impact of this virus here in China and
that has knock-on effect around the
world you know there are a lot of
factories auto factories in particular
down in Hubei Province those are shots
those will be shut indefinitely until
they can get a handle on how this virus
is spread and what they can do to
contain it so you know we're gonna have
this supply chain issue moving
forward like right now it's it's kind of
a bit of a grace period because most of
those the factories would have been shut
for the Lunar New Year holiday coming
back online probably on Monday that's
not going to happen
what's that knock-on effect going to be
we'll have to see thank you Scott
Heidler in Beijing Hong Kong's chief
executive mu mullahs rejected calls by a
medical union to close the border with
mainland China to try to halt the spread
of coronavirus 13 cases are confirmed in
Hong Kong when hey is there for us the
authorities in mainland China are
struggling to get on top of this given
that those statistics that are announced
daily from the National Health
Commission certainly worse than the
previous day 46 deaths confirmed on
Friday and those latest numbers that
were announced on Saturday morning by
the National Health Commission most of
the infections and the fatalities are
being recorded in who Bay Province still
that is where it is thought that this
outbreak began and certainly there the
medical staff are struggling to deal
with the sheer number of cases thousands
of extra doctors and nurses have been
sent to the area from other parts of
China but there is still a shortage of
medical equipment there in particular
the protective suits that those medical
personnel need to wear when dealing with
the patients and also test kits and that
is partly why many experts outside China
are saying that the actual number of
infections will be a lot higher than
what the Chinese government is recording
also there is a shortage of hospital
beds and that's why everyone is eagerly
awaiting the completion of two makeshift
hospitals that are being built in that
provincial capital Wuhan city we expect
those hospitals to be completed within
the next week or so and that will mean
an extra two and a half thousand
hospital beds but this virus has now
spread to every single province and
territory in China including Tianjin in
the Northeast a long way from Hebei
province but a city that neighbors the
capital Beijing there are 32 confirmed
cases in Tanjung and the provincial the
local authorities there the local
government have announced that they are
ordering all schools and non-essential
business to remain closed
and from Hong Kong to Thailand Alexey
O'Brien is in Bangkok where Thai
officials have been giving an update on
the virus there they have confirmed that
the number of confirmed cases remains
unchanged at 19 but the number of
suspected cases here in Thailand has
jumped to 344 from 280 on Friday they're
not saying that's because the virus is
spreading much faster here it's actually
because they've widened the net they're
now looking at people who have arrived
from cities outside of Wuhan via the
epicenter of that outbreak but also
Thais who may have come into contact
with Chinese tourists for example
because China is the biggest source of
foreign tourists for Thailand they have
been about 2 million people come through
just in December and January since the
outbreak began so if you have a look at
the map behind me though there has been
a map made up to show the outbreak as it
stands at the moment that big red circle
is will Harland and China's herbo
province the as I said the center of
that outbreak and down a little bit here
you can see the red flashing dot that is
Bangkok and that's because the Thailand
has the second number highest of cases
at 19 outside of China and also
authorities here say Thailand remain
remains the most at-risk country outside
of China because of the number of people
traveling back and forth but that number
19 is dwarfed by the number if you moved
with mahiette of 11,000 11300 that's the
number of global cases most of them
though are in China